ellers standford hat einen autokorso
organisiert um den sieg von joe biden
und kämmerer harris zu feiern
mehr als 50 wagen sind unterwegs durch
philadelphia
wochenlang hatte die ärztin sich für die
demokraten eingesetzt als aktivistin
mitgewirkt bei blackwater smet schwarze
wähler zählen
vielleicht wird alles gut
nicht dass wir so naiv wären zu denken
dass plötzlich alles zur normalität
zurückkehrt und alle sich frei fühlen
aber wir wollen kurz innehalten tief
ausatmen und anerkennen dass eine
veränderung bevor steht vor dem
kunstmuseum von philadelphia trifft sich
aller standort mit mitgliedern ihrer
studentenverbindung dass eine von ihnen
es ins weiße haus schafft ist für sie
alle ein wichtiges zeichen
wir sind eine afro amerikanische
schwarze organisation und
vize-präsidentin kamera harris ist ein
mitglied dieser organisation
1908 wurden wir gegründet und dies sind
alles meine schwestern auch pastor
michael robinson widmet seine predigt
dem wahlsieg wegen der korona pandemie
muss der gottesdienst in der
baptistenkirche in nord philadelphia
online stattfinden
nur ein paar mitglieder der gemeinde
sind persönlich gekommen
wir hatten eine wundervolle
präsidentschaftswahl mit einem
wunderbaren ergebnis
die leute haben in den straßen getanzt
sie haben geweint mit freudentränen und
ich bin sicherlich ein teil dieser leute
ich war begeistert über diese letzte
präsidentschaftswahl und das ergebnis in
nord philadelphia ist pastor robinson
eine autorität er nimmt mich mit zu
einem spaziergang durch das viertel in
dem überwiegend schwarze und latinos
leben der stadtteil ist landesweit
bekannt die armutsrate liegt bei über 45
prozent die kriminalitätsrate zählt zu
den höchsten in den usa
ich treffe einige jugendliche die sich
freuen dass er mit ihnen reden möchten
sie haben eine klare vorstellung davon
was sich ändern muss und drücken es in
musik auf songs über polizeigewalt und
rassismus wir brauchen nur eine faire
chance schau mal wie private schulen
organisiert sind zwölf kinder im
klassenzimmer das brauchen wir auch
es geht darum wir unsere schulen
aussehen es geht um die bücher die wir
haben
die sind von 2002 wir haben 2020 dass
joe biden versprochen hat strukturellen
rassismus zu bekämpfen ist hier
angekommen
ich hoffe beiden wird es richtig machen
alle haben ihn gewählt
wir probieren das mitnehmen du siehst
wie unser viertel vor die hunde geht und
die offiziellen machen nichts um uns zu
helfen
ich hoffe die nächsten vier jahre werden
sie das richtige machen
der demokratische senator reid evans ist
in die baptisten kirche gekommen um sich
bei pasta robinson zu bedanken für die
unterstützung im wahlkampf
viele kirchen in nord philadelphia
hatten für joe biden geworben aus seiner
abneigung gegen trump noch der pastor
keinen hehl
er hat nichts getan er hat gesagt er sei
der einzige präsident seit abraham
lincoln der etwas für die
afroamerikanische community getan
das ist eine und wir wissen hat viele
neben erzählt ich bin froh dass er geht
und dass wir jemanden haben der
kompetent intelligenter und ein gefühl
für das hat was dieses land braucht
ich treffe oder stanford wieder die seit
sechs uhr morgens auf den beinen ist die
ärztin die am vortag noch so fröhlich
mit einem autokorso durch philadelphia
gefahren war ist ziemlich besorgt
angesichts der wachsenden corona
infektionszahlen die organisation black
doctors für diese ehrenamtlich arbeitet
führt auf dem gelände einer kirche in
philadelphia kostenlos tests durch es
wäre wird jetzt eine führung zu haben
eine klare stimme die sagt gouverneur
von pennsylvania veranlasse masten
pflicht und wenn du keine maske trägt
dann sind das die konsequenzen
dass mittlerweile bis zu 17 prozent der
tests positiv ausfallen ein
alarmierendes zeichen für die ärzte
immer mehr von ihnen stecken sich selbst
an die zeit des feierns ist vorbei
der druck zum handeln das wird überall
in den straßen von philadelphia deutlich
ist groß die afro amerikaner sehen sich
nicht nur bei der verbreitung des corona
virus auf der verliererseite
über 90 prozent von ihnen haben joe
biden und kämmerer harris in
pennsylvania gewählt und hoffen nun auf
schnellen wandel